ja liebe Userinnen und User soweit also
die Pressekonferenz der Behörden in
Hamburg wir fassen noch einmal kurz
zusammen acht Menschen sind gestorben
gestern Abend bei einer Amok Tat in
einer Kirche der Zeugen Jehovas in
Hamburg darunter der Täter selbst das
jüngste Opfer war ein ungeborenes Baby 7
Monate alt erschossen im Mutterleib acht
weitere Menschen sind verletzt worden
darunter vier schwer die Polizei das
wurde eben in der Pressekonferenz
deutlich hat offenbar verhindert dass es
sehr viel mehr Todesopfer gegeben hat
denn wir rekonstruieren noch mal den
Tathergang 50 Menschen befanden sich im
Gebäude als der Täter von außen durch
die Fenster schoss dann durch das
Fenster ins Gebäude eindrang und dann
dort auf die Menschen zielte und dann
ist offenbar genau das ähm passiert was
unser User hier Klassik über Youtube
hier sehr treffend beschreibt das
Polizeipräsidium ist ungefähr 3 Minuten
von dem Tatort entfernt und deswegen
denke ich mal dass sie so schnell vor
Ort waren wenn man die Pressekonferenz
genau verfolgt hat dann ist das genau
passiert um 21 Uhr gegen die ersten
Notrufe ein um 21 Uhr waren die ersten
Einsatzkräfte vor Ort am 21 Uhr dann ein
Spezialkommando woraufhin der Täter in
den ersten Stock geflohen ist und sich
dann dort Entschuldigung offenbar selbst
richtete über den Täter sprechen wir
gleich wir haben nämlich unseren
Reporter vor Ort Ralf Zimmermann von
Siefert steht für uns im
Polizeipräsidium
Ralf du hast die Pressekonferenz
verfolgt ich möchte noch mal hier kurz
in den Chat sehen ich sehe nämlich hier
bei den Userinnen und Usern sehr viel
Beileid sehr viel Kommentare Mitleid für
die Angehörigen und ich sehe aber auch
sehr sehr viel
Hochachtung und Respekt vor der Arbeit
der Polizei wir können uns hier zwei
drei Kommentare ansehen
Hendrik Engel schreibt zum Beispiel
danke an die Polizei und C12 schreibt
Hamburg zeigt wie man mit solchen
Einsatzlagen umgeht stärkste Polizei
Deutschlands ähm die Hamburger Polizei
Ralf kennt ja viele verschiedene
Einsätze geht 20 die rebens mal
Entführung viele mögliche Beispiele aber
wir haben bei den Herren auf dem Podium
gesehen dieser Abend gestern das war ein
ganz besonderer Einsatz
ja das war ein besonderer Einsatz und
das was du gerade über die Hamburger
Polizei gesagt hast will ich gar nicht
den will ich gar nicht widersprechen
aber es war gestern tatsächlich auch
insofern viel Glück dabei als eben eine
Spezialeinheit die darauf geschult ist
bei Anti Terror einsetzen im Grunde
sozusagen die
unterstützungs-liga zu sein dass die
gerade auf dem Weg zurück ins
Polizeipräsidium waren und quasi auf
diesem Weg direkt dorthin konnten dass
die war noch nicht mein Polizeipräsidium
selbst das hätte länger gedauert also es
war ein Riesenglück dass sie sich in
diesem Hamburger Stadtteil als darauf
befanden
Reifen wir haben auch viel kritische
Nachfragen von Journalisten Kollegen
gehört da wird es trotzdem dieser sehr
guten Arbeit viel aufzuarbeiten geben
wir haben gehört es gab einen anonymen
Hinweis in Bezug auf den Waffen besitzt
des Täters kannst du noch mal sagen was
die Polizei zum Täter gesagt hat und was
möglicherweise da jetzt an Diskussionen
anfangen wird wie man diese Tat hätte
verhindern können
ja das ist tatsächlich glaube ich der
heikelste Punkt in dieser ganzen
Pressekonferenz und dem ganzen Fall
bisher der Hamburgs Polizeipräsident
Ralph Martin Meyer hat gerade noch mal
gesagt es gab in im Rahmen der
rechtlichen Möglichkeiten die es gibt
ist dieser Mann überprüft worden
Tatsache ist Philipp F ist deutscher
Staatsangehöriger lebt seit ungefähr
zehn Jahren knapp 10 Jahren in Hamburg
und hatte einen Waffenschein den hatte
er erst Ende letzten Jahres bekommen im
Dezember glaube ich Anfang Dezember
bekommen und es hat dann im Januar
dieses Jahres also vor zwei Monaten
einen anonymen Hinweis gegeben dass
Philipp F irgendwie ein merkwürdiger
Mensch sei und dass man sich den doch
vielleicht mal näher anschauen sollte
daraufhin hat es eine Überprüfung
gegeben durch die Behörde die auch die
Waffenscheine ähm observiert und vor Ort
eine Überprüfung gegeben und diese
Überprüfung ist zugunsten von Philipp F
ausgefallen weil der die war aber
ordentlich verschlossen wissen es
handelt sich um eine
halbautomatische Handfeuerwaffe und die
war ordentlich verschlossen in dem
entsprechenden Waffenschrank es gab eine
Patrone die wohl irgendwo rumlag das ist
moniert worden und das ist auch von ihm
sofort eingestanden worden aber es gab
keine rechtliche Grundlage in irgendwie
zu belangen auch psychisch
möglicherweise zwar etwas zu vermuten
denn das war offensichtlich Inhalt
dieses anonym Schreibens aber keine Hand
habe dagegen jetzt rechtlich eine
Rechtsgrundlage zu haben dagegen
vorzugehen dass Philipp F weiter diese
Waffe führt und deswegen ist es dann
letztlich wohl zu dieser Tat gestern
gekommen die eben jedenfalls mit den
Rechtsvorschriften die es bisher gibt
nicht verhindert werden konnte und Ralf
Martin Meier der Hamburgs
Polizeipräsident hat gerade auch gesagt
man müsste jetzt einfach mal schauen was
dort schief gelaufen sei denn ganz
offensichtlich ist ja etwas schief
gelaufen aber es kann gut sein dass man
die Rechtsgrundlagen dann auch noch mal
überprüfen muss und ähm aufgrund von
solchen anonymen Schreiben immer eine
ausgedehntere Untersuchung dann
veranlassen muss die ist hier nicht
gemacht worden bei Philipp ff
Ralf Zimmermann von Siefert vielen Dank
für diese Einschätzungen danke dass du
die PK für uns mitverfolgt hast
Dankeschön nach Hamburg und wenn ich
hier in den Chat gucke dann ist
natürlich ein ganz großes Thema der
Tatort und der Täter nämlich die Kirche
der Zeugen Jehovas und darüber sprechen
wir jetzt hier im Stream und zwar mit
dem religionspsychologen professor
Michael
Utsch er ist abrupierte Psychotherapeut
und er leitet das Referat und das muss
ich nachlesen Religiosität und
Spiritualität in der Deutschen
Gesellschaft für Psychiatrie
Psychotherapie Psychosomatik und
nervenheilkunde danke schön dass Sie da
sind Herr Professor Utsch sie haben die
Pressekonferenz mitverfolgen können
und da möchte ich jetzt natürlich die
Tatsache herausgreifen dass der Täter
offenbar ein ehemaliger Zeuge Jehovas
war und wie in der Pressekonferenz
zitiert wurde er hegte eine besondere
Wut auf religiöse Anhänger vor allem
aber die Zeugen
Jehovas er war wie gesagt ehemaliges
Mitglied hat die Gemeinschaft Zitat
freiwillig aber nicht im guten verlassen
wie schätzen Sie das alles ein
naja der Glaube an eine höhere
Wirklichkeit oder die Zugehörigkeit zu
einer Religionsgemeinschaft
kann sehr stabilisierend sein und sehr
viel Unterstützung geben im Lebenskrisen
aber der Glaube ist leider auch die
Religion
fähig zu ganz schrecklichen Taten und
seit 15 Jahren wird
sexualisierte Gewalt in
Religionsgemeinschaften sehr genau
angeschaut
wir müssen also schauen was
Religionsgemeinschaften dazu beitragen
und
Aussteiger Personen oder aussteigen
willige Witze wird nicht einfach gemacht
also es gibt leider genug
ehemalige Mitglieder die geächtet werden
und die das als ein starken seelischen
Stress empfinden und meine erste
Vermutung ist natürlich auch dass er
enttäuscht ist das was er wütend gewesen
ist
und dass er im Affekt dann zu so einer
schrecklichen Tat gekommen ist wir
schreiben zwei Userinnen und User die
eine schreibt das auch noch mal was sie
gerade gesagt haben Stefanie Hoffmann
über Facebook die Zeugen hierhovas
echten ihre ehemaligen und Sebastian
Liebmann schreibt wenn du bei den Zeugen
austrittst dürfen deine Verwandten und
Freundin bei den Zeugen nicht mehr mit
dir sprechen und dich nicht mal
anschauen
Herr Professor und ich glaube es ist
wichtig dass man Trend den Täter als
Einzelperson und das Thema Aussteiger
bei den Zeugen Jehovas denn der Ausstieg
bei den Zeugen Jehovas alleine macht
einen natürlich nicht zum Täter der
sieben Menschen erschießt das ist aber
vieles was jetzt hier so gemutmaßt wird
können Sie das ein bisschen einordnen
man fragt sich ja immer wenn so eine
schreckliche Tat passiert was können die
Motive gewesen sein und das waren
studierter Mann wie ich gehört habe der
auch unauffällig gelebt hat der der in
einem
normalen Umfeld tätig war berufstätig
und und so unauffällig war
dass er jetzt aber dann in eine
Gemeinschaft zurückgeht wo
er früher mal offensichtlich zu Hause
war und wo er einen ja auch eine
spirituelle Orientierung bekommen hat
das geht natürlich zu denken das muss
man jetzt noch genauer anschauen
es gibt eine neuere Studie von der
Universität Zürich von einer
stressforscherin die
ehemalige Mitglieder aus christlich
fundamentalistischen Gruppen befragt hat
und bei den über 600 Fragen hat sich
eben herausgestellt dass dieser
Glaubenswechsel oder dieser aus eine
extreme Lebenskrise hervorgerufen hat
eine
Gemeinschaft die früher Halt gegeben hat
Orientierung
war vielleicht in einer gewissen
Situation ganz hilfreich aber Jehovas
Zeugen sind eben
sehr regide da ändert sich überhaupt
nicht
im Vergleich zu anderen
christlichen sondergemeinschaften
bewegt sich da gar nichts kritiker
werden dann am schnellsten mit
Gerichtsverfahren behandelt und sie sind
also sozusagen nicht lernfähig und das
beklagen viele aus gestiegen ehemalige
Mitglieder das dass dort dass sie dort
auf eine sehr gute autoritäre Struktur
stoßen die nicht lernfähig sind lassen
sie uns noch ein bisschen genauer auf
diese Gemeinschaft gucken man kennt ja
manche prominenten Zeugen Jehovas
Michael Jackson zum Beispiel ähm ser
Williams zum Beispiel Naomi Campbell ist
in diesem Glauben erzogen worden soweit
man weiß es gibt weltweit rund 8,7
Millionen Mitglieder in Deutschland sind
es ungefähr 170.000 und das ist auch
deshalb so wichtig denn natürlich war
nicht nur der Täter Zeuge Jehovas
sondern auch die Opfer waren Zeugen
Jehovas was können Sie uns über diese
Gemeinschaft über ihren religiösen
Zusammenhalt erzählen
diesen ursprünglich
angetreten als ernste Bibelforscher und
wollten also die Bibel sehr wortwörtlich
auslegen
und sind dann aber sehr schnell in so
ein Denken verfallen
haben bestimmte Verse aus der Bibel
rausgenommen dass
das Ende bald nah ist sie haben versucht
das Ende dieser Welt zu berechnen es
wurden also Jahreszahlen aufgrund von
Prophezeiungen errechnet und das war
erst 1874 und dann als es trotzdem mit
dem mit unserer Erde noch weitergehen
wurden andere Jahreszahlen berechnet das
ist eine Gruppe die schon von einem
baldigen Welt in der ausgeht und wenn
man jetzt die aktuellen Entwicklungen
sich vor Augen hält Krieg in Europa
Epidemien Seuchen
Naturkatastrophen das sind ja alles
gesellschaftliche Faktoren die auch so
eine Endzeit Stimmung
unterstützen und das kann viele Menschen
verunsichern ängstigen und dann kann so
eine Gemeinschaft
Trost stiften weil man sagt das wahre
Leben kommt erst in Jenseits dass die
Welt hier ist schlecht und dieser
Dualismus diese Trennung zwischen Gut
und Böse das wird bei Jehovas Zeugen
sehr ernst genommen man soll den Kontakt
mit dem Bösen mit der verseuchten Welt
und Satan beherrschten Welt meiden und
das führt zum kann auch eben zur inneren
spaltungsprozessen führen gerade
seelisch instabile Menschen die dann
auch so eine leere treffen können wenn
darunter letztlich Schaden leiden und da
muss man genau hinschauen damit nicht
solche Taten weiter passieren und ein
Ergebnis dieser Studie in Zürich ist
eben auch dass die professionelle
Begleitung von
ehemaligen Mitgliedern verbessert werden
muss es ist interessant der der Wachturm
das ist ja die große Zeitschrift der
Zeugen Jehovas die Nummer eins in diesem
Jahr hat das Thema psychische Probleme
und da immerhin wird dort schon gesagt
wenn man eine seelische Erkrankung hat
sondern professionelle Hilfe suchen aber
andererseits wird auch gesagt
es ist möglich ein ein Leben ohne innere
Konflikte und ein vollkommen glückliches
Leben zu führen wenn man Mitglied bei
Jehovas Zeugen ist und solches so ein
Versprechen dass ein Leben ohne innere
Konflikte und Leiden möglich ist das ist
natürlich utopisch und das stimmt nicht
und auch nicht aus psychologischer sich
sagt der religionspsychologe Professor
Michael Utsch vielen Dank dass Sie bei
uns im Stream waren und vielen Dank
liebe Userinnen und User dass sie heute
wieder mit dabei waren machen sie es gut
tschüss